indecision right I said already today
you've heard it before in Bettina just
an abbreviation mathematicians we love
abbreviations because we are ladies if
you want to write less rather than more
so for example of what are the
operations that you send many times
already in like five times six this
itself is it abbreviation right it's an
abbreviation for among other things
5 3 plus 5 Plus 5 Plus 5 Plus 5 plus 5 I
can count cool okay we don't like rated
it to go right to just takes forever you
can say it in a much more condensed form
right and that's exactly what indices do
five to the power of six
just like multiplication is an
abbreviation of addition you can think
of indices as an abbreviation of both
position I should have picked the number
smaller than 6 but you guys okay now we
start with thinking about it this way
but very quickly run into weird ideas
like we said before Oh 5 to the power 0
doesn't really fit the definition that
we just developed which is repeated
multiplication this means you've never
multiplied it in the first place
but we looked at how we saw you can sort
of like reverse engineer what's going on
and we came up with an S and we said
that it's 1 because to get from 5 to the
power of 1 to 5 squared right that's 5
that's 25 well now if you reverse the
logic this is what I showed you
yesterday if you reverse logic that gets
you to 0 going off the ladder you divide
by 5 every time so that's what gives you
1 okay and the same way and you did see
the flaw here which if I'm going to go
to ultimately where you come up with a
meeting for this it makes a little sense
as multiplying something by itself
0 times what's it mean to multiply
something by itself half the time
you it's really easy to work out what's
going on just by following the logic of
what you've already know okay
we established you've got two numbers
with the same what's that number again
at the monocle a base it's going to
liver the same base and you multiply but
then what do you do indices and if you
add them write that check out now half
on the heart is just 1 so therefore the
right hand side I have five five to the
power of one do you agree by the firing
on time no it's our 125 are you
following with me I'll starting at the
stallion let's let's look back in it and
again we did before right
you told me this I think this is what we
did become management wasn't numbers
same base different indices you tell me
to and the indices yes eight a powerful
so over here it's the same deal better
eighth I've got five instead of a 301
I've got okay class so when I get out of
here I add those powers which are pops
up on top one I checked this is one
nobody thank you envision I don't should
searching this meeting them now I'm
pretty comfortable that we can all agree
the price that have one is fun now
here's a big fight the tower half
history object what is it it's some
number that you multiply by itself that
gives you five well I know what that
number is in hand the name we call it
less you
it's only product we called the square
root of five don't we that's the number
that you multiply by itself
viki's you find by definition so if you
look at this and now I'd like you to
picture comes up if you start in writing
and this line here okay if you think you
have 5/4 power of 1/2 you're like I
don't know what it means in terms of our
original definition in terms of
multiplying over and over again because
there's no never again it's like you
don't even get to a full multiplications
1/2 if you just follow the rules that
we've established ourselves when you
multiply with the same base you add the
indices then this is what emerges right
5 to the power of 1/2 is the square root
of 5 now you can extend this logic with
other you write if I change the power
again so still a fraction but different
so my they didn't say five and five of
third if I multiply this by itself
nothing much interesting happens but if
I multiply our third time I'm
multiplying Donna's they all have the
same base so what will I do with the
indices I will add them 1/3 plus 1/3
plus 1/3 gives you 1 1 again
so whatever five to the power of
attorney is it's a number you multiply
it by itself three times and it gives
you five we have a name for that number
what is it it's the cube root of five
okay